yeah hello and welcome to this video
playing dokie dr. John that's the cool
opponent and it's quite funny huh I
played the game before that which ended
in an interesting draw but I had forgot
to press the record button so there is
no recording of that there is a bit of a
bit of a shame for that had happened to
that didn't happen to me for a very long
time and I was like at the end I wanted
to check in and and name the file
properly and I was looking on like hmm
there is no file what happens here okay
what is dr. John none up to isn't that a
pretty awful line for black I don't
quite understand the setup so what does
he play with a quick p5 here or
something and I'm curious to see how it
is going to continue I don't believe in
this kind of position from black at all
[Music]
what you see doing here there are
sometimes ideas to to sacrifice h6 in
such a position if black plays this is
this is basically declaring bankruptcy
so we'll see wants to play nine to seven
and then be five should be far as you'll
see three or you can still under this
kind of position of course how to do it
nice the five is a good move I can also
play with a four and one def nice the
five is good yeah let's talk bad for
what okay so why does a big spoilt for
choice in
97 36 hanging he might have 9 a-6 to see
seven No ok so I'm going to prepare the
connection of looks that was the idea I
get it now a little bit late right ok so
what we should be six a five will win a
pawn I just wonder if this is actually
helping me that I've see no reason not
to I mean giving up a dark squared
Bishop here Ricky can try to sacrifice
something here it doesn't wouldn't have
led to much problem well if the black
goes g5 this is really basically I mean
it's basically winning for widest
position after after the this side of
the board is closed but after I still
look for a like f5 something crazy
they're here we go he has to do
something like that normal normal stuff
doesn't cut it so now White's position
is winning but then you know he can try
all kinds of all kinds of stuff before
in particular it's the thing that my
team might be a problem before threatens
is three or so I wonder if I should just
play before here I mean my bishop looks
strange but before we form hmm for
stuff to prevent this before each one
Teague's III check ok I'm going to play
it I have to make sure that i'm not
losing on time or something like that so
ok take this you can only take one thing
at a time ok so here he has to take
either the rook or the night and I think
it rather takes the night here just to
keep it more confusing if it takes a
look I think 94 is probably going to be
fine he might have g4 then I think you
will or this one or this one going for
complete confusion but night is form
[Music]
this is also hanging I mean of
unprotected does this thing I have 94 as
well with that night see for all night
be three actually why not might be 3d 5
is not hanging less we should see form
yeah then this is probably good ok so if
he takes their queen g5 is going to
happen
918 excuse I've then I 25 is dangerous
it is dangerous if I shake it okay I'm
taking it i don't know i'm probably
getting major now or something and one
was on time I don't see a maid at the
moment yeah now we can he can start to
take stuff I'm still literally winning
would probably just be should be five or
something like that is going to be
tricky but I can take night see form and
I don't know I spent a bit too much time
there is miring my position trophy
okay he's got this creature h1 business
that is going to be dangerous King g3
maybe try to pick this up Kingi 323 this
kind of thing looks like a decent
defense Queen d3 also for Queen to g6 I
mean it's not great but I would probably
take a draw here simply for the time
situation I will shoot this should be
five crap sorry ok so I'm bailing out
him
I would probably win our term position
is probably a draw can I try to offer a
drawl here with this is of course okay
check check check check check check
[Music]
check check lake sometimes it can get
back to you here try to win on time ok
this is this is the result that is this
correct from position here but why did I
spend all that time I don't know
sometimes I really don't know where I
spend all the time yeah so after g5 this
is a winning position for white
basically because black has 0 count of
tracking site is closed the only thing
we can do is try this Hail Mary
counter-attack what he did in the game
and this is this shouldn't work but it's
literature so I feel maybe he had
something in ok so I took all that and
maybe be three yeah you know f500 the
engine is this is this is getting
dangerous so I should have not played
this super like I have all the time in
the world move be three but you're
actually taking you to and get out of
this I mean I just need like one or two
move
to make f5 completely impossible like in
g2 on maybe like knight to e three or so
I already want to pawn them which I
actually didn't like so much because it
took so much time to play the computer
here wants to play a fork in G 291 as a
stronger I'm getting this point anyway I
should have probably just played more
for making sure that at five never
actually happens because the Queen side
is collapsing anyway so yeah this is
actually getting or in FOIA that's
getting extremely messing extremely
messy what she did not like so much
rather comp initially but yeah I don't
know I don't really think that def 19 or
something adequate him not if force
stronger attacking the rook end in three
this is the main thing that King g2
would have prevented if I have kinky to
earlier then there is no e3's III threat
now what a month posted earlier like
this now I mean this is a messy note
that basically almost all my pieces are
unprotected so I mean it's just really
really messy now we are answer here
before it was really tough to play then
basically forces before and take so the
engine actually likes my way of
defending Bishop a one i would i would
have thought I wanted to click night
before but I just see that he takes it
with the Queen so that wouldn't have
worked this is actually ok according to
the comp
yeah if you can t wanna ha i would have
never played kingdom one year just this
one check shootie excluding takes is a
complete mess okay and this this doesn't
work in but it is still a reasonably
dangerous of course and the look and the
piece up this is what I did ultimately
look see one yeah you know I thought
about this but Jay I had some check this
is this is winning okay that looks
dangerous to no end look F to check now
Kim I can have a million pieces up and
I'm threatening stuff myself son yeah I
know it was clear they accomplished and
find a clean windows okay this is
actually also also I did a good job here
defending this only probably hear Nexus
b5 stuff 92 escutcheon getting the
knight to f3 this is five so i can
actually play 92 huh I know what I
overlooked yeah just take the bloody
palm okay now I just overlooked that I
can take the pawn this cost me to
chicken out with queen d three images
yeah which is getting getting to this
ending which is the draw also objective
they chose to draw you should set us
keep the keep the King back with because
this g5 I think I'm probably winning the
engine is not giving me a complete win
but what is the line XD eggs in a 6-53
7 huh that's a funny position I let the
draw right I can bring the King up
[Music]
I can actually just go around to the
queenside i think i can just going on to
the Queen sound of course yeah I am I
going on man of course nope ok so he
cannot allow the breakthrough yeah okay
it was a bit of a bit of a mess and he
declined my troll also trying to win on
time sometimes it gets back to you but
it's very interesting to see that event
around here I should definitely not play
clay this which get some really back
into the game just just something like
that I know the engine wants to play
forward it doesn't matter and when you
on the Queen 30 anyway I just have to
prevent him from from from lashing out I
ok this is probably better because it
makes sure that I win the poem at the
end what about f5 here by the way I mean
an important difference is that here I'm
covering this this bottom yeah there is
nothing and ok b3 also does not open up
that diagonal huh that's important yeah
I group reflecting move able to make
this a pretty smooth game problem but
this this way it got extremely messy ok
guys thanks for watching